am donnerstag findet auf dem
firmengelände der apg austrian power
grid ag ein festakt statt grund dafür
ist die partnerschaft zwischen der apg
und dem österreichischen bundesheer die
austrian power grid ag überwacht das
stromnetz in österreich und stellt so
die stromversorgung sicher die
kooperation zwischen bh und apg bringt
beiden seiten einiges wir tauschen uns
regelmäßig
aus mit dem mit den gegen zeitliche
erkenntnissen hinsichtlich der
sicherheit das ist ganz wesentlich auch
für uns und die apg hat ja auch sagte
ihre nachrichtendienste im
energiebereich und das ist für uns von
großem nutzen auch im bundesheer dass
das thema blackout zurzeit so intensiv
diskutiert wird wie schon lange nicht
mehr ist nicht ganz grundlos österreich
steht mit dem umstieg auf erneuerbare
energien vor dem größten um und ausbau
der stromnetze in der vergangenheit war
so dass spezielle thermische kraftwerke
sehr genau unseren verbrauch gekannt
haben und genau diesem profil nach
gefahren sind mit dem umbau jetzt mit
den erneuerbaren ist es so dass wir auf
einmal kraftwerke hoben die auf einem
ganz anderen standort stehen erlöse und
auch in ganz anderes erzeugungs
verhalten haben weil ein windrad dreht
sich eben nur wenn der wind weht und die
sonne
produzierten strom wenn eben die sonne
scheint das heißt es passt unser
verhalten dass verbraucher mit dem der
erzeuger nicht mehr zusammen und wenn
dann auch noch dazu die die netze zu
schwach sind und die netze nicht in der
lage sind in genau diesen strom erzeugt
wird auch zu den kunden zu bringen dann
kommt es zu überlastungen der netze und
das führt dann unweigerlich zu problemen
dann wäre wirklich ein blackout
vorprogrammiert bereits 2009 10 haben
experten beobachtet dass österreich rund
dreimal nur haarscharf an einem
großflächigen blackout vorbeigeschrammt
ist darauf hat die apg reagiert was wir
gemacht haben präventiv
wir haben gaskraftwerk in österreich die
aus der marktsituation heraus nicht mehr
fahren würden weil es einfach zu teuer
sind weil sie sich nicht mehr rechnen
die haben wir zum der vertrag genommen
und mit diesen kraftwerken ganz speziell
bedarfsorientierten mich dann wenn keine
sonne scheint wenn kein wind rad sich
dreht dann auch strom zur verfügung
haben national zur verfügung haben und
auch die leitungen zu schwach sind um
einen import zu gewährleisten genau dann
haben wir jetzt kraftwerke unter vertrag
circa 3000 megawatt und die kraftwerke
können wir dann ganz spezifisch für
diese zwecke einsetzen trotzdem muss das
stromnetz so schnell wie möglich
ausgebaut werden ein ausbau tempo wie zb
beim straßennetz davon können die
stromnetzbetreiber nur träumen ich
glaube das ist die subjektive
wahrnehmung von uns allen wenn man auf
der straße im stau steht dann denkt man
sich gott im himmel warum gibt es
nirgendwo als stärkerer größere straße
dritte sport eine vierte spur und und
nun das ist ein bild das eigene
wohlbefinden dass man damit damit
verliert wenn man im stau steht beim
strom spürt dass keiner strom ist nicht
sichtbar wir merken es nicht für die
meisten menschen kommt der strom aus der
steckdose noch immer kann aber auch sich
gedanken was dahinter passiert und jetzt
wird es erstmals durch diese gaskrise
auch in russland transparent dass es
denn eine ihrer logistische aufwand ist
der dahinter gemanagt werden muss damit
strom wo immer in europa gekauft wird
auch zu jedem zeitpunkt bei ihnen in der
steckdose ist und genau dieser umstand
ist mit ein grund dafür dass verstärkt
kasernen autark ausgebaut werden das
wirkte
insofern mit dass unsere sensibilität
unser unserer bewusstsein welt tägliche
herausforderung es bedeutet dass strom
aus der steckdose kommt und damit auch
für unsere kasernen und damit ganz klar
das ist kein automatismus dass ist kein
gottesgeschenk wir müssen vorsorgen für
den zeitpunkt wo der strom nicht aus der
steckdose kommt und der wird kommen die
frage ist nur wann sind die experten
nach wie vor überzeugt